today we're going to explore new worlds
the worlds inside the VR anything can
happen you've seen that video where the
guy is trying to kiss the anime girl
[Music]
that could be us oh my god it's time for
me to press end this moral fresh flesh
and become is that a car is that a cop
car that's me what is happening hello
how are you
bring oh please don't hurt me
how's your babe man of your day I'm just
gonna go I'm just gonna go away from you
thank you
shut up police isn't pupusas what are
you gonna do fight me you want to go
then this bro you know what wait where
do you go you can teleport I'm gang dude
your chicken out pretty good I'm sorry
are you I knew it get out of there will
be no top of the morning to you really
weird it sounds right away okay okay I I
move to buy to the same week you [ __ ]
did oh how good does mine you copied me
it's I mean you can't beat Jack don't
you my brother that's cold man a plus
makes me give you do it I just realized
it's me
oh my god this is mental oh my god are
you making the video please don't tell
me y'all make don't worry your sake does
anyone want to play Minecraft anyone
want to play Minecraft Jesus Christ
anybody plays overwatch here maybe yeah
racism thank you so much
[Music]
the horse please not [ __ ] me when you
can't sure that's how we trained you
oh no I went away Jesus Christ let it
take long for them to recognize me what
the hell no no no no they leprechaun I'm
not a leprechaun I rip out your lungs
okay that's offensive okay please
apologize that's a microaggression
please listen I'm not a lie guys cuz it
I am jacksepticeye top of the morning to
you laddies
I love potatoes please spare me okay I
hate potatoes because I am NOT a
leprechaun wait how does he work totally
dangerous potatoes weather lady indeed
I'll be on my merry way
I am jacksepticeye top of the morning to
ya hey what is that guy's oh my god it's
Rick for Rick and Morty I love Rick good
morning Oh God
[Music]
alright let's just get out of here and
while no one notices just crawl out just
crawl out no one will notice
who wants some free gold and potato your
big quiet how dare you you see the
weight Y to you thank you sir
you want a new avatar go through that
portal without portal I just want to see
what rolling me right I'm not dude man
I'm not going
this guy better not pick trolling me
okay there's more advertiser oboe what
the heck I'm gonna pick this one this is
as close to an anime babe
didn't work then they work I think
you're worthless is it dude I'm gonna
try it out I'm going back hey where do
you find that I matter I want to look
like an anime schoolgirl as well now
keep that I need help I need your help
ah what is this fuzzy looking thing get
her away from me back up no I said back
up what does he do it get shush shush no
shush I said shush with you oh my god
what are the giant lady go oh my god oh
you want to challenge me you want to
challenge me oh you want to tell me you
want to do it your finger out of my face
you want to do it huh but you think
square oh yeah
square up Jax quick I mean the side the
side I'm right here
oh this is so dumb
they game on the katana monsters Digimon
you're a champion